welcome it is time for drew's news we
cast out our line
and we reel in that good old news tuna
uh-huh catch a keeper
and with me at the desk is my chicken of
the sea ross matthews
um okay well first up i found this story
to be a total delight our favorite girl
dakota johnson that's right her and i
do um the little yellow book
and um her company tea time we curate
lists together so she's a dear friend of
our show and she just revealed one of
her favorite hobbies people reports that
dakota says in her spare time she loves
to crash weddings what how fun is that i
just rewatched wedding crashers this
weekend too so i'm i was primed for this
um one time she said she was holding up
a bride and groom in a chair i mean what
havin aguila i love it and um they
looked down and they were like oh
whoa what are you doing here
um dakota you little minx i love this
about you all your layers come crash our
show or a wedding anytime soon
have you ever crashed anything rossi i
would never crash a wedding in my life
especially since i'm planning one now
all i'm thinking myself is like that's
three shrimp that's three shrimp right
we plan ahead hey uh what about this
there's a big trend on tick tock did you
see this about finding your main
character energy it's all about being
the star of the film of your life well
uh well and good reports there's also a
ton of value in celebrating something
they call supporting character energy
right because we all want to be jlo i
know we do but sometimes you got to be
judy greer oh i love judy cruz me too so
much it's okay to be the ron weasley and
not the harry potter you understand like
and um i feel like i get to do that for
you like i'm here to help support you
and i i i love being your
little supporting actor
i mean
you do it's funny i always think of the
word co you know like i think of us as
total equals and i will be your
supporting girl any day oh i love you
flower girl you're charlotte
i'm just so happy to be in it with you
and so i love you and you are the
starring character
i'm your supporting girl
i love you too
well spring is in the air um but one
town in england has uh carpeted flowers
in the town thanks to one man the good
news network reports that more than 100
000 daffodils are blooming in syd myth
okay they're a gift from banker keith
owen he passed in 2007 and he left his
life savings to the local conservation
group to grow a million flowers over
time i wonder who's counting right um
every year volunteers plant bulbs around
syd mouth and the town that's the town
where his mother lived
i mean i know whoa this one just gets me
because i grew up in washington state
and we are known for our tulip festivals
and our daffodils and my mom always had
them in the front yard and they still
you know because the perennials they
come up every year so even though she's
no longer here they still come up and
even though this man's no longer there
they still come up and just this morning
it's so funny i didn't know we were
going to talk about this story but just
this morning i walked outside of my my
new house that i got here and there's
like some snow still in the corner but
there's some daffodils popping up so i
just felt like maybe it was a sign from
my mom and then to see this story it
just makes me feel
so wonderful that there's you know oh my
life goes on you know um
last night i was like scrolling
instagram and i felt like i really
needed something and i i i was scrolling
and scrolling and scrolling and i come
up across a quad picture of my
grandmother dolores costello really on
old hollywood fans one of my favorite
instagram accounts and she's there and i
just started hysterically crying
so
keep your eyes open
and something will eventually come up
that's a great sign that things are
going to be okay and they are okay
and um because they'll come like they
really will when you need them
[Applause]
[Music]
you